Campanelli couldn't get it rebound back
history here come the Bulldogs the other
way go to battle we'll take it in with a
lot of the Florida State defense but
again saying it looks like they have a
break but look at the guys in black come
flying back
[Applause]
it's man over three be back collected by
Clark anymore
I had lives in individual support
parachute
so boy that he was just hit but Hashem
or Iran in the way until you began the
season with a beautiful feed from Chile
on top be able to get into this play to
me this is a silly foul the dumped by a
Kimura and then the reaction by Kevin
Kelly once he knew he was B there's the
contact on the backside Turner
behind the back Edwards checks against
now look at this no this is not the
perfect situation for Timmons the shot
clock down the nine fly can't dribble
himself free he's gonna have to take a
long one five step back three four the
time
[Applause]
this dude 22 second half points 27 for
the game for Ryan Klein the benches
react actually what they got Moretti
it's moody Moretti tees water
and this is very interesting you draw
the defense and then you kick it out to
Moretti now he is a really good
three-point shooter who has not shot the
three wells so far that 17 minutes left
in the first of all that went up high
and Owens caught up if he wanted if you
shoot 18 a game now they're on their
heels a little bit or a little strangely
right now only just that huh Oh am i
right on the ball and it's 76-59 other
North Carolina just not getting into a
flow white the speed and slam
and a chance at three watch him turn the
corner and if you just for a second arm
back there waiting for him it's way too
late
good call from the officials pretty
impressive after crashing to the floor
hitting two free throws for doing rim
about this big time leave the
chandeliers put the China way with this
guy around the house rookies say that
should be outlawed because right over
ties back to six the largest lead of the
game at Virginia Tech and as Jones
[Applause]
hi can you go put this I thought that
was going out of bounds
against Kansas some of the haircut the
four minutes will be sensational
[Applause]
Davis curls goes Corey Davis jr.
creativity cop-out the clutching of the
basketball just then and reloading
inbounds pass and watch this one down
and Murray load on the way down